what's going on people today we're going
to be theorizing how the entire plot of
attack on titan would have changed if
irvin was chosen to inherit the colossal
titan
in this video we'll explain how the war
against mali would have had a completely
different outcome and how those events
would change the future of the island
along the way we'll also be expanding on
certain subplots from the main show
including military police corruption the
importance of the tiber family and
whether or not historia will inherit a
titan
before we get into it don't forget to
smash that sub button and drop a like if
you want to see more content like this
and be sure to stick around till the
very end of the video so you don't miss
the biggest surprise of this whole
series so far
okay so part 3 picks up where the last
video in this series left off with the
weimar titan confronting the scouts in
liberio given everything that's happened
it'd be pretty obvious to her that zeke
has betrayed marley and before anyone
can react she sends spikes directly
through the beast titan this would be
followed up by doing the same thing to
aaron as well meaning that within just a
few seconds lara tiber would have viewed
her hardening against three separate
enemies in response to this zeke would
call out for his pure titans to defend
him and across the city they'd each
start running towards his direction
at the same time mikasa would spring
into action from the rooftops and fire a
solid amount of thunderspears at the
warhammer titan's neck this massive
explosion would send it crashing into
the ground as if it was dead giving the
egg rose an opening to free themselves
from the spikes of hardening i imagine
zeke would then take a minute to free
flock's pure titan which was suspended
in the air from the previous video while
captain levi was swooped down to
retrieve the helpless rhino
outside the internment zone commander
evan would still be walking around in
his colossal titan but he'd begin to
emerge as a whole fleet of airships
descend from the clouds these airships
would all belong to hizuru's army and
their arrival would be part of the wider
plan to defeat mali within the next 12
hours the combined forces of asia and
paradise are planning to force the
marlies to surrender by launching
coordinated attacks on their key
military bases this includes destroying
the airship base in fort salter as well
as other significant locations and the
scouts will need to split into teams for
this to happen
with irvin having seemingly destroyed
molly's chain of command in the last
video the next 12 hours is super
important as it's best to strike now
before marley has any chance to
reorganize itself
as the airships get closer evan would
then fully exit the colossal and hit
torreira to the center of the zone where
the warhammer titan is fighting for its
life
at this point all of zeke's pure titans
are now in the area forcing lara to
defend herself from peak's dad poco's
mother and flock not to mention constant
thunderspirit attacks from mikasa
in a situation like this the warhammer
would have to keep using more and more
hardening to stay in the fight which by
default drains more and more energy
now after the side poco would have
manifested a new draw titan so he can
try and take down aaron but zeke would
make a move to defend his younger
brother
in particular he'd command his last
remaining pure titan to attack and if
you do the math you'll realize that this
time here is actually pogo's own father
earlier that night mr and mrs galliard
was spiked at dinner with zeke's spine
of fluid alongside reiner's mother and
peak's dad but with karina being
squashed in the last video only three of
the parents became titans when zeke
eventually screamed the beast would try
to psych poco out by telling him this
and it wouldn't take long for the
warrior to realize that this isn't a
bluff since the titan attacking him
would look exactly like his own dad he'd
then look over to see his mother
fighting against the warhammer and this
is the moment when his soul would break
in too
galliard would consider for a second
whether he should just let one of his
parents eat him but while he's
distracted levi would pounce in to chop
off the draw titan's legs with aaron
following this up by ripping off his
arms and smashing his face into the
ground meanwhile the warhammer titan
would also be getting seriously
overwhelmed and in this moment she'd
have to use her last drop of energy
which is precisely what zeke had been
waiting for
his strategy from the beginning was to
wear her down using his minions and
having now witnessed her final desperate
attack he'd launched a pitching assault
to finish her off
the beast would then tell his pure
titans to stop fighting as he goes to
examine the warhammer's body and after
finding the trail and following it he'd
eventually find lara's titan crystal
while that's happening commander ervin
would arrive on the rooftops to observe
the situation and he'd watch on as zeke
tosses the warhammer crystal to eren the
reason he passes it to his brother is
pretty simple but in order to explain
it's best to do a brief flashback
two years ago when parodies in history
would have begun planning this invasion
zeke would have helped out by sending
intel about the strengths and weaknesses
of each warrior because of this intel
the scouts have known for a while that
the draw titan can break anything and
with galileo being defeated aaron
instinctively shoves the crystal inside
his mouth he then lifts polka into the
air and uses him like a nutcracker which
grinds lara's body down to nothingness
and as eren drinks her spinal fluid he'd
gain the powers of the warhammer titan
following this aaron starts the goal of
script as he begins to eat porko as well
but the commander would shout from the
sidelines telling him to stop
months ago it was already decided who
would inherit the draw tie-in if
everything went to plan and the person
selected was louise to be more specific
she would have definitely volunteered
herself as she's always had that
mentality that you can't do anything
without power louise would likely think
that by inheriting one of the nine
titans she could elevate herself to a
similar level of strength and importance
to mikasa and ultimately that would be
her core motivation
as a consequence of this selection
everyone would keep shouting until aaron
finally gives up and the commander would
then maneuver down to retrieve poko's
body himself
in the process all three of the warriors
have now been captured by the survey
corps and the plan is for the drawing
armor titans to be eaten here in liberio
when it comes to the cart titan everyone
will want to keep her alive for
insurance purposes because if someone
gets injured on the battlefield then her
titan can be used to bring them back to
life
anyway aaron would then exit his attack
titan and i imagine that him and the
other scouts would have final things
they'd want to say to ryanair before he
dies once that's all said and done zeke
would give flock's pure titan the order
to eat him and sadly for him there
wouldn't be enough pod armor to save the
warrior this time around
everyone would be watching on as flock
choose rhino like a piece of gum and as
a quick side note i reckon that irving's
first choice to get the armor time
wouldn't have been flock but actually i
think it would have been jon his
leadership qualities would have made him
one of the ideal candidates to inherit a
shifter but after speaking with hanji
about it they realized that making this
choice would probably damage their
relations with eren
soon after flock would have completely
finished eating rainer and louise would
now be preparing for her own
transformation just like flock she drink
a vow of zeke spinal fluid and the
advantage of doing it this way is that
her titan can be controlled this means
if something goes wrong they can always
improvise as a time that can follow
instructions is a lot more useful than
one that just does what it wants
sometime after louise drinks the fluid
she maneuvered down to the ground and
gives zeke a signal to let him know that
she's ready the beast would then scream
at the top of his lungs for the second
time today and once she's a pure titan
he'd waste no time in ordering her to
eat porco
as she goes to take a bite out of the
warrior a large explosion suddenly
happens out of nowhere in a nearby part
of the internment zone the building that
exploded was the one where the car titan
was being held and from where i've been
standing he can clearly see the flames
taking over
in response he'd instantly send levi and
a few others to take a good look while
everyone else stays where they are to
make sure nothing happens to louise
meanwhile on the streets of liberia
commander mcgath would be on the run
with pique as the two of them are trying
to find out what's going on having both
recently escaped near-death situations
the only intel they know for sure right
now is that zika switched sides mcgath
would therefore want to find answers by
running in the direction of the beast
titan's last scream and a few minutes
later they arrive in reiner's old
neighborhood
from a distance the two of them would
observe as louise emerges from her pure
titan and seeing this would make it
fairly obvious that marley just lost one
of their shifters i think magath's first
thought would be that louise must have
eaten the warhammer because across the
battlefield there'd be a bunch of
hardening left behind by lara tiber
as pique scans the area for any sign of
reiner and porco she noticed that
standing next to zeke are three familiar
looking pure titans their calm behavior
would indicate that they've been created
by the beast titan and by looking at
their faces i'm pretty sure she'd wonder
whether she knows these people
peak being peak i'm sure it wouldn't
take that long for her brain to start
putting the pieces together and she'd
soon remember the wine that zeke gave
them to drink
at the same time up on the rooftops
commander ever would now be eager to
move on to the next phase of the
invasion his aim is for the scouts to
split into their respective teams and
get on the airships because if they stay
in liberia much longer then he'll only
end up risking lives for no reason
because he wants to wrap things up he
docks sashikoni and jean to kill the
three remaining pure titans in the area
while peak watches on in complete shock
by now she's fully realized what zeke
must have done to her dad and mcgath
would have to hold her back as she's
desperately trying to run to him
remember the whole reason she became a
warrior in the first place was so that
mr finger could get medical treatment
and in doing that she's proven that
she's willing to sacrifice her own life
in order for him to live in that sense
it would be very in character for her to
try and get herself eaten by him so that
he can turn back into a human but
there's no way mcgath would want that to
happen for a start he'd remind peak that
her dad likely wouldn't want to survive
if it meant he had to eat his only child
in the process
the guilt would be way too much for any
parent to handle and mr finger would
also become a target for the scouts if
he inherits the cart titan for those
reasons pique was stopped to think about
whether sacrificing herself is the right
thing to do but before she can decide
jean swoops in and kills her dad
instantly
seeing this from a distance would
understandably make peek hysterical and
she'd likely just want to rush in there
and get revenge because her dad was her
only family that being said mcgath would
try his best to convince her not to and
the two of them would get into a heated
debate about what they need to do next
now in case you're wondering about
captain levi he would have arrived
outside the burning building alongside
the other scouts who were sent along
their main priority here would be
finding any survivors with hanji and
nard being two of the people who were
supposed to be inside at first levi
would call out to hanji from the street
but after not hearing any reply the
captain would 100 make the decision to
go in the flames inside would be so
intense that i don't think even he'd be
able to survive for long but what he'd
do is quickly sprint through the
building trying to find any signs of
life
as he enters the room where the cart
titan was being held he'd noticed body
parts all over the floor and off to the
side he'd see hanji's broken goggles
based off all the damage in the room
levi assumes that something happened
here that triggered a thunderspear
explosion although right now he doesn't
have time to investigate as the flames
continue to get more and more intense
the captain would pick up the goggles
from the floor as he makes his way out
of there and on his face there'd just be
a glam expression as he exits the
building as the other scouts approached
him he let them know there were no
survivors and in his mind the car titan
has to be the one responsible one way or
another pique managed to escape while
everyone else in the room was blown to
pieces so clearly something must have
happened and levi would tell her
subordinates to search the area for
clues on where she might have gone
switching back to reiner's neighborhood
by this point the survey call would
begin separating into their different
teams and eren's team arguably has the
most significant job their mission would
be to completely destroy fort salter
which is an airship base located in the
south of the continent the weapons found
in that base are some of the most
dangerous that the malians have to offer
so if it was flattened to the ground
then mali surrendering becomes a lot
more possible however because fort
salter is so far away from liberia
aaron's team would actually need to
travel there by flying boat which is a
faster type of plane created by his rune
by contrast commander evans team is
meant to be travelling to the north of
mali by airship where they plan to
attack two important naval bases
given that zeke is part of evan's group
he finally exits his beast titan after
all this time and a random scout swoops
in to take him onto the aircraft
everyone else then starts to maneuver
onto their respective ships except for
the commander as he's still be waiting
for levi to come back having waited long
enough he decides it's time to head off
in the direction of the burning building
himself while the remaining scouts
continue to grab rise out of the
internment zone three of those remaining
scouts would be sasha connie and jon who
would be on the rooftops trying to
remember which ship they need to be on
in particular connie and sasha would be
slightly confused but jean would remind
them that they need to be on the same
ship as the beast titan as the three of
them have a brief conversation before
they leave a quick flash of lightning
would appear behind them followed by the
card titan rushing in to swallow jon the
shifter would then rapidly jump from
rooftop to rooftop with him inside his
mouth and peek would be long gone by the
time that sasha and connie even react
several minutes later the cart would
arrive in a secluded area of the
internment zone where commander mcgath
would already be waiting
after congratulating pete for getting
the job done she'd release jean from her
mouth and the general would take him
into one of the empty houses nearby
this house is where the interrogation
would begin and they start asking him
questions about zeke's relationship with
the scouts as well as what parodies are
planning to do next on top of that
they'd also want to know reiner and
pogo's location but jean would stay
quiet the whole time until magath aims
his gun
we've always known that jean is someone
who doesn't want to die a pointless
death so you know he wouldn't want to
get his head blown off in this abandoned
house with a gun being pointed directly
at him his new plan is to stall until
connie and sasha arrived because he'd
have faith that they would be able to
find him as a consequence jean would
begin responding to a peak in the
commander's questions but he tried to
confuse them by giving them a ton of
vague answers that don't really go
anywhere eventually this would frustrate
mcgath to the point where he starts
personally breaking the scout's bones at
which point jon would tell them that
there's no way marley can win now that
parodies has the founding titan this of
course would be referring to the fact
that they now have the founder and a
titan of real blood but at this stage in
the timeline peak and mcgath didn't know
that a titan of royal blood was required
from their point of view parodies
already had the founding titan so jean's
statement would be something that would
definitely get their attention
while they interrogate him further to
understand what he meant coney and sasha
would be on the streets of liberia
trying to find him being an experienced
hunter i think sasha would be especially
good at tracking peaks titan footprints
and before long they'd arrive near the
secluded area as they continue their
search they suddenly hear the sound of a
gunshot from one of the nearby buildings
and as they head towards it mcgathan the
cart's item would make their escape from
the area
upon finally reaching the house that
john was being kept in they'd find him
lying on the floor losing a ton of blood
and the nature of the injury meant
there'd be nothing they could do to save
him the only way he'd be able to survive
is if they turned him into a pure titan
here and now but neither of them would
have any of zeke's spinal fluid or any
of the titan transformation serum
instead they keep shouting at jean to
keep his eyes open while they head back
to the ship but with his final breath i
think he'd tell them both to live
comfortable lives when this is all over
which is something that he'll never get
to do
back at the burning building levi and
evan would be reunited as the captain
hands over hanji's broken goggles he
tells the commander his theory that nala
and hanji were killed by the kart titan
and the loss of two close friends would
definitely be a shock even for someone
like him however with the scouts about
to potentially face the final stage in
the war against mali evan would
understand better than anyone that this
isn't the right time to just stand
around and grieve instead i'm sure he'd
thank levi for salvaging hanji's goggles
and he'd proceed to give a motivating
speech to the remaining scouts in the
area
following that everyone would make their
way onto the airships and on the ground
peak and mcgath would watch on as the
ships all head in different directions
over the next 12 hours an all-out war
would break out across the marine
continent with aaron's team devastating
fort salter
using their titans he and flock would
destroy every single airship at the base
while luis would go on a wild rampage
killing tons of enemy soldiers given
that this is her first time becoming a
shifter i think it's natural that she'd
eventually start to lose control hence
why mixer would be here to deal with
louise and flock in case things get out
of hand
on the ground aaron's team would also be
supported by soldiers from his route who
would parachute into the base after
arriving in separate flying boats
simultaneously on the opposite side of
the continent evan and zeke would be
traveling to their targets by airship as
always zeke's hidden motivation is to
complete the euthanization plan but on
the surface he's been helping parodies
to plan this invasion for the past two
years during that time he gave them
valuable intel to gain the commander's
trust and once the war is over he
believes that he'll finally be accepted
onto the island and allowed to speak to
eren evan on the other hand would see
things a lot differently and i'll try to
explain his thought process
considering that the beast titan
massacred the scouts evan would have
zero faith that he actually wants to
help them meaning that zeke must have a
hidden motivation while the commander
wouldn't know for sure what that hidden
motivation is it doesn't take a genius
to realize that it's something to do
with the founding titan because of this
everyone understand that parodies has
what zeke wants and as yelena revealed
the warriors wouldn't be returning to
the island anytime soon what this meant
is that zeke's last remaining hope to
come to the island and meet his brother
it's dependent on the scouts and so
ervin used that to their advantage for
the past two years the commander forced
the beast titan to prove his loyalty by
sending them valuable intel and this was
all in the promise that he'd get to talk
with his brother in the end zeke had to
accept this proposal because he quite
literally had no other option to get to
paradise and after everything he's done
he assumes that ervin now trusts him
in reality he'd already made plans for
zeke to be detained underground as soon
as they arrive on the island and if
everything goes to plan he'll never meet
aaron again
in that way both of these men have
hidden motivations that they're hiding
from each other but on the surface
they're pretending to be comrades
19 hours after the attack in liberio the
mali military would have suffered their
worst day in recent history forcing
willie tyber to think about their
options with fort salter being destroyed
marley no longer has any weapons that
can kill titan shifters meaning they're
pretty much helpless if these attacks
continue
as willie considers what they should do
next commander mcgathan peak would
arrive to discuss what's going on
based on the information they were able
to get from jean they now know that zeke
is a titan of royal blood and that
together the jagebros can activate the
full potential of the founding titan
from marley's point of view this means
the enemy can nuke them with the
rumbling at any given time making this
whole situation even worse than it
already was
the smart thing to do would be for them
to surrender before they get trampled
but there's a couple of reasons why
they'd hesitate reason number one is
that commander mcgath would be thinking
of peak because if molly surrenders then
it's likely she'll have to go on the run
to avoid being captured and eaten
reason number two is that if they give
up then it probably means the return of
the eldian empire which is something
that the entire planet has been afraid
of for the last 100 years despite that
peak would suggest a crazy idea that
involves allowing both of those things
to happen because in the scenario that
they find themselves in it might be the
only way to strike back at the enemy
after hearing the plan willy would have
to think hard about it for a while
because if they do what she's proposing
then it means the end of mali at least
in its current form the upside however
is that if this works they'll be able to
get revenge for the family they lost in
liberio and the three of them will be
known as heroes who save the world just
like hellos for those reasons willy
would agree to set peak's plan in motion
and several hours later the alliance
between his room and paris would receive
a communication this communication would
be an official notice of surrender from
the malian government on the one
condition that parody stops with their
ongoing attacks of course the surrender
is what evan had been hoping for the
entire time and after two years of
preparation the scouts would have
managed to defeat the biggest military
force on the planet the fallout from
this victory would have huge
ramifications in all corners of the
globe but first let's do a quick recap
of what would happen on the island over
the next few weeks and months
to start things off all surviving scouts
would come back home to a hero's welcome
but for members of the 104th cadets the
celebrations would be overshadowed by
something else aaron and mikasa in
particular would only find out about
jean's death once they arrive and to say
they'd be devastated is putting it
lightly not only was jean a close friend
that had a huge impact on their lives
but after losing armin a few years ago
this death would make aaron feel like a
broken man
during the following days there'd be
funerals for all of the fallen soldiers
and on top of that there'd also be big
political changes too
firstly everyone would have now led the
scouts to impossible victories in
shiganshina and in mali itself and so
his level of popularity across the
island would easily reach legendary
status having sensed the overwhelming
public opinion zachary would announce
his intention to retire at the end of
the year with evan being chosen as his
successor as commander-in-chief zachary
is head of all three military branches
and so at the end of the year that
responsibility would be passed down to
the colossal titan the knock-on effect
here is that the scouts would also need
someone to replace evan before the year
is up but with hanji and jon both dying
in the war two of the best potential
candidates aren't even a possibility
in terms of ranking levi would be the
next logical person to be commander but
he almost certainly wouldn't be
interested so the door would be left
open for other people to make their case
for it in terms of other big changes for
the island the next inheritor of the
female titan would be another big issue
for the past four years annie has been
chilling inside her crystal but as shown
in liberio with lara tiber the scouts
have a solid blueprint for breaking her
out of there using louise's power they
can crush annie and feed her spinal
fluid to appear titan but the question
is who would be worthy of eating her
this is where the politics creeps in as
the crystal has been in military police
custody ever since she was first
captured given that the mps have been
looking after annie this whole time the
higher ups would feel like one of their
people should be the next female titan
doing this would drastically improve
their declining image with the average
citizen perceiving the mps as useless
and corrupt despite them technically
being the most prestigious military
branch as a consequence they'd pull some
strings to have one of their soldiers
selected and the specific person they'd
want to inherit the female would be
hitch it's not that hitch would be the
best candidate for the job but rather
her story is what would improve the
image of the military police as annie's
former roommate who was betrayed and the
main person who looked after the crystal
they could easily spin this into a
narrative that would gain the respect of
ordinary people of course hitch herself
would be reluctant to shorten her
lifespan just so the mps can look good
but the higher ups would try to bribe
her with huge financial incentives
at first i think she would consider
accepting this however this shady
scenario would remind her of marlow and
his crazy ambition to clean up the mps
seeing a real chance to try and make
that dream a reality she would agree to
inherit the female titan but only under
certain conditions
the condition she proposed would be the
first big step towards wiping out
corruption in the military police and
the leadership on the island would
personally agree to make sure it happens
as a result seven months after the
victory against mali a ceremony would be
held in which annie's crystal is crushed
by louise and fed to hitches pure tyson
in the process she'd become the fifth
member of the titan shifter unit
alongside flock louise aaron and of
course commander evan
now in case you're wondering about zeke
he'd currently be locked up as a
prisoner in this special mountain
facility this secret facility would be
far away from civilization and the beast
would have been brought here only a few
hours after the war was over
it's important to remember that levi was
on the same airship as these two and so
as soon as they touched down on the
island the captain would have instantly
chopped off zeke's limbs and his tongue
to stop him from transforming from there
the beast was taken to this special
prison which was specifically made so
they could restrain him away from the
rest of society unfortunately physique
being betrayed by irvin has meant that
he's not had any chances to speak with
aaron about the euthanization plan and
with his time as the beast titan running
out it's not looking good
anyway switching over to the continent
there'd be some big changes there as
well with the maling government now
being under his ruse control
from the beginning the main goal of the
azmobito was to restore their nation to
its former status and that's now become
possible thanks to all the weapons the
land and the resources they've gained
from this invasion
that being said around the world there'd
be a very mixed reaction to the news of
his taking over and i'll explain the
reasoning behind this
to start things off the reason mali was
so hated was because they used titans to
invade a ton of countries and so in that
sense a lot of people would be happy
that they lost however as a result of
marley losing the island devils now have
eight of the nine titans including the
founder making them way more dangerous
than the warriors used to be
this level of strength would cause many
nations to be afraid of what ld is
planning next and in particular they'd
fear that what just happened to mali
could also happen to them the
combination of lds titans and history's
weapons is a force that can destroy any
country on the planet and so these
countries would be feeling pretty tense
about the situation to help ease these
tensions the azam and beta would grant
independence to several nations
colonized by mali including on yankon's
home country and this would be an
attempt to prove that they can be
trusted on a similar note elder would
sign a declaration promising never to
use pure titans but there's a reason why
these promises wouldn't be enough to
stop the growing hatred against them
ever since the war ended willie tiber
would have been using his influence
behind the scenes to manipulate public
opinion it's been established that the
tigers have strong connections to very
important people and seven months ago
peak's theory was that these connections
could be used to form an alliance
against elder because willie believed in
this plan he fled the continent after
mali surrendered and since then he's
been going from country to country
warning politicians about the dangers of
the rumbling he'd explained to leaders
of every nation the significance of
elder now having the founding titan and
a titan of royal blood and people would
take him seriously because of how well
respected the tiber family is
as a consequence it wouldn't take long
for anti-elder and anti-israel
propaganda to start appearing in
newspapers
as this would be used to generate more
fear towards the island the story that
would be told to the world is that the
jaeger brothers are planning to revive
the old elden empire and that hizrah
were helping them by giving the island
weapons and technology
eventually all this panic would lead to
the formation of a secret military
alliance just like peak predicted and in
the present day her plan to get revenge
would be in the final stages
back on the island the military
higher-ups would be holding talks about
what they should do next as things
wouldn't have played out the way they
expected although their invasion of mali
was successful elder itself is now
perceived as the new biggest threat
making them a target for the entire
world
with zeke's time running out they also
have fewer options to defend themselves
because when he dies they'll no longer
be able to do the rumbling of course if
historia was to eat zeke then they could
hold on to that rumbling power for 13
more years but making her do this comes
with certain downsides
from the beginning aaron has been
aggressively against the idea of
historia becoming a titan and during
these talks he told the commander they
need to find another way
if they let her become the beast titan
then it would mean all their sacrifices
in liberia were for nothing since ld
would still be relying on the rumbling
for their survival the whole point of
their invasion against mali was to
secure a future where the rumbling
wouldn't be necessary and so aaron would
feel that in memory of everyone that
died they can't allow historia to be
titanized
to an extent everyone would understand
where aaron is coming from with this and
a couple days later he'd invite the
queen and all members of the titan
shifter unit for a meeting the purpose
of this meeting would be for him to
reveal a certain proposal he's come up
with and this proposal is guaranteed to
protect the island while potentially
saving historia's life at the same time
for a bit of context at this stage in
the timeline the government wouldn't be
interested in getting into a war with
the rest of the planet and right now
both elder and history would be trying
to engage in peace negotiations with the
enemy nations that want to kill them for
that reason it's too soon to know for
sure whether the island will need the
rumbling for its future survival and a
consequence of that is that it's also
too soon to know for sure whether
historian needs to inherit the beast
titan
the problem here is that in a few months
time zeke is gonna die due to the curse
of emir so someone has to eat him before
that happens otherwise ldl will lose the
power of his shifter as a result
everyone will make the decision that one
of the current scouts will be chosen to
inherit this shifter and whoever that
person might be when they eat zeke the
island will no longer have a titan of
royal blood
having no titan of royal blood means
that ldl will lose its potential to do
the rumbling in a few months but
irving's secret plan will allow them to
reverse that decision if they need to to
put it simply for the rest of their
lives flock kitchen louise will take
turns acting as historious personal
bodyguard and at all times they'll need
to have a syringe spinal fluid if
there's ever an emergency that requires
elia to use the rumbling these three
will need to be prepared to die for
their country by allowing themselves to
be eaten by the queen's pure titan
in the process historia would become a
royal blooded titan shifter but this
would only ever happen if a path to
peace becomes impossible
this solution is better than forcing
astoria to become the beast just because
zeke is running out of time and it
leaves open the possibility that she can
live a full life without ever needing to
be titanized
furthermore with ervin about to step
into zachary's role his main focus as
commander-in-chief will be improving
diplomatic and economic relations with
other countries so that they never have
to use this nuclear option
i think at first hitch would be too
stunned to speak about this proposal
while [ __ ] louise would be more
likely to accept that they might have to
be sacrificed
meanwhile historia would begin to tell
the group her thoughts on the plan but
before she can finish their sentence a
random soldier bursts in to tell them
something's wrong the soldier would go
on to reveal that at this moment their
hidden facility in the mountains is
under attack with an unknown enemy
raining down bullets from the airships
what the scouts wouldn't know though is
that on the inside of this facility a
familiar face has taken advantage of all
the chaos and managed to infiltrate the
prison
dressed up in the survey core uniform
pique would come face to face with zeke
for the first time since he turned mr
finger into a pure titan although he
wouldn't be able to speak because he has
a gag in his mouth she'd reveal to him
that ever since they first met it always
felt like he was lying but despite that
she never considered that he betrayed
the warriors the fact that after
everything they've been through together
he was still willing to get reiner porco
and her father all killed it's proof to
her that he's an objectively evil person
who deserves everything that's about to
happen
going beyond their personal grudge the
coordinate is a power that also can't be
trusted in the hands of the jaeger
brothers and so pique would bite her
thumb to transform into the cart titan
in this form she pounces forward to kill
him by crunching through his spine and
she snaps off the top half of his body
as she chews into him she technically
merges the kart titan and the beast
tyson into one but more importantly by
doing this she's taken away elia's most
powerful weapon which sets the stage for
the global alliance to make their next
move
with that said that's the end of part
three of what if evan got the course of
titan and if you liked it then i
appreciate if you shared the video drop
to like and subscribe so you don't miss
future videos like this
i also want to shout out all the
different artists who drew things for
this video their links are in the
description so be sure to check them out
especially valupio who designed the most
pieces out of anyone
as always thanks for watching and i
appreciate your patience in waiting for
this to come out because it did take a
lot longer than expected and until the
next one peace out